so here we are we're in addis ababa and
as you can see we're getting lots of
local culture here and we're here for a
project to actually help with physics
training physics teaching carnival
tamale Benita economist we're here for a
joint project all about physics teaching
and over here we have all the other
people involved in the project
we have two representatives from the
Institute of Physics who've been here a
number of times before bill Poole and
Christine Cleve and then we've got Jared
Emma Jeremy and Thiago we arrived here
on Friday we were fairly tired so we
spent most of the day we're looking
around various different historical
sites and outer suburb I
the food reservation room but I guess
maybe it's food preservation move room
these hooks are used to to store slabs
of hang up slabs of raw meat and that
raw meat is actually eaten raw as well
so it's um
culturally it's very very interesting
silence
it's really amazing really really
fantastic beautiful view behind us so
tomorrow we will head down so divide us
up about to a place called Adama and
that's where the physics teacher
training is going to happen and I'm sure
Sean is going to be filling us along the
way just me for me come okay okay go
over here do not like a joke he reckons
it's a fantastic view from down here Wow
why why what's your name beautiful thank
you thank you so Malaika here has them
taking a stand to to a place where
there's just an absolutely astounding
view right across outer suburb and the
distance and just that the wonderful
beautiful beautiful landscape it's
fantastic
move it exhausted after trying to keep
my balance going down there but it's
it's it's a really really impressive
view thank you thanks Marco
just a minute oh it's down good eat
we've arrived at Goro else ranked at the
pronunciation Department you mentor all
they are I'm not very good at rolling
hours compare Lee pronounce ours at the
best a time but here as you can see a
guru preparatory school this is why
we're here to do training course for you
can see the teachers who are all around
and we're going to be involved in
sharing what we do in terms of
experimental physics and you know I'm
sure we get some insights from them as
well in terms of how they teach physics
what's remarkable is that the teachers
have come from 11 different regions some
of them as far away as a thousand
kilometres or maybe even 1500 kilometers
so it's it's a big event for them and
it's a big event for us as well no
pressure at all no show and absolutely
hope for
you
important thing here is that Richard
Feynman was a theoretician so he writes
down his theories and then it's people
who do experiments come along and check
his theories
yeah party plaintiff Arabic and from
Annelise came by
you come from Angela Samuel you see game
and how fun was the matter for me
especially neutral subjects
and how we kind of defense
dude doesn't so much Kentucky for me
when we plot experimental data we
plotted as points we don't join up the
dots because there are no measurements
between those points so we plot the
points and then we draw fit line through
those points and it's it's a bit of a
cob Barrowman it's a minor thing but a
bit of a book
so it's going really really well this
morning we did a number of presentations
just about the scientific method by the
experimental methods in general we did
really nice session on Hookes law which
is really straightforward just a mass on
the end of a spring measuring the
extension and getting in the ideas of
plotting a graph etc and then we also
did an other really nice experiment
little cars going down the slope in
terms of acceleration and thinking about
how would plot a graph to work out the
acceleration now we're playing with
slinkys and we're going to wander
upstairs and see exactly what they're
doing with slinkys just being really
impressed by how friskiness problems
across just types of longitudinal
transverse words can sort of engine
however speed changes without the mass
per unit attention each other we are
going to try and repeat the wonderful
slinky experiments that Christine did we
swap round so we demonstrate different
experiments throughout the day and at
the moment I'm unraveling a slinky and I
finally nearly about - how do you
disentangle this bloody thing you know
amazing I was saying slinkys were before
it's shown or not watch how long it
takes for this pulse to die down
keep going keeps going keeps going keeps
going keeps going right left one of the
problem in our scores are teachers to
emails thank you very much
we are the truth we can
interesting they can look for duties
with the materials
there are water bottle straining sounds
like an overused common absolutely
definitely what's the best thing you've
done so far
Betty the best thing yeah just enjoying
these doing experiments
now we can work out how sick this line
is in terms of the area so how many
layers of atoms there are on this page
first movie filled so what you do when
you make these measurements it's
essential that you sample folded and
then do that make one that's little make
another majority make another lease
agreement
it's going okay I think there was some
confusion at the start and I explained
it quite as well like they didn't quite
get the point to it so I had to
explained a couple of times why we're
flossing the graph but not just how
connected the bodies were they're
getting on with it and they're getting
the practice and that's the important
thing
the Wellness of the material is going to
represent its temperature so we are
transferring the water into the sponge
so the equivalent of transferring the
heat energy into the material
I am an electron in the valence band I
can't go anywhere they're all in the way
there's no way I can go I can go if I'm
here no electrons I figure moon so three
measurements is okay five measurements
is good ten is even better have you done
anything like this before
so it's the end of the second year its
unfairly tired the rest of us are fairly
tired but it's such a such a privilege
to be here the enthusiasm the love of
learning the love of knowledge is
fantastic being asked so many questions
Emma's experiment on graphite went
particularly well Thiago's experiment
went well Jeremy's been having fun so
much fun playing around with electronics
which he loves and Jarrod's
enthusiastically helping out right
across the board it's wonderfully um the
heat is oppressive I sweat all the time
and when you're continually
concentrating and running from place to
place all did it can be quite exhausting
but it's a good type of exhaustion and
when you get to the end of the effort
yeah you know it's been it's been good I
think we've achieved something so it's a
lot of the time have to shout above the
din of this in the background but um
that's not bad thing
we're going to children's a radio one
and a really high one do you best
everybody do together I mean everybody
would be happy
so let's go oh
Oh
okay good enough not good enough
change the scale again Oh
getting back back one last go three two
one
right now I'm gonna go as high as I can
go
good
not bad thank you very much Philip me
CIA team is convinced that hood okay see
I'm hearing my Scott thanks to God John
Young Harry XIV here picks out of here
a mescal mescal right inserted long end
is the positive side we know that
magnetic field lines means align the
three presents the magnetic field
strength around a magnet it can everyone
see can you see can see the water tear
or clothes yeah yeah you see
to some extent definitive lack objects
will wrap around the sellers this couple
more inert is 0.6 0.5
so we've now got to the end of the
training course of the Dharma were
travelling back from a dharma to artists
and we stopped midway between the Dharma
and artha so it's absolutely stunning
absolutely beautiful you can hear you
listen as well delighted at how well the
course has gone but rather disappointed
that I missed the last two days of it
because I was rather ill it's just
fantastic here it's just sort of
everything you think Africa would be
Jeremy here is paddling away and driving
us in roughly the right direction we've
got such a great time exploring the
environment here it's just it's just
amazing absolutely amazing
so come to an end were flying home we're
all extremely knackered extremely
exhausted it's been immensely fun it's
been immensely enjoyable I hope what
we've done has been worthwhile we
certainly want to continue links I think
the teachers got a lot out of it
the only disappointment for me was
because I got sick I really wish that
hadn't happened
and I've also mocked up Shaun's
continuity because I've had a shave
really sorry about that but my face was
so sweaty I had a shave anyway going
home and misses the Opia but I must
admit where I won't miss mosquitoes
really won't miss the mosquitoes
Oh
more papers everyone's finishing and
they need to do more we're gonna need
more elements 13 months its aluminium
sunshine them yeah aluminium 13 is there
are 13 months in the Ethiopian calendar